[Music]
dance
[Music]
[Music]
cause you'll be
[Music]
[Music]
can be thrown away
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
your
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
like a 6am
[Music]
we'll walk into the sunrise
[Music]
[Music]
welcome everybody
welcome to the stuttering john podcast
this is your favorite
world famous host stuttering john
melendez and a somber morning for me
there's the link if you want to donate
paypal dot me slash john melendez inc
uh
benny loco with the badge beau bird is a
sex worker and she's had two abortions
are they teddy's aborted babies
inquiring minds want to know then
there's 126 thousand that teddy gave
to bobert
what was that payoff for i wonder
says benny my mom is here marco v193
william nichols
uh
this thing jumped already can you
believe it already
um
facebook people during this broadcast
you could support my page by sending
star as a digital gift that helps me
earn money andrea brower my moderator
love you baby
thanks for being here forest richie from
forests of
azor yeah marco v 193 i'm a little early
today because i wanted to chat with you
papa blue howard's hair
praise for sean caston and his family
what happened
please tell me something didn't happen
to my buddy
could somebody let me know
linda mcewen
any 68
seymour butts
tammy pearson
linda mcew and ronda reese
artist caverlin jolie jackie hobson
the squeegee
kevin murphy technology by atlantic
lauren ipsum how are you
benny loco thanks for the five bucks hit
that thumbs up share out and happy
tuesday y'all
alien connie heather john
weddington
oh it's june 14th thanks john
i put june 13th what the hell is wrong
with me
uh well
well we all know what day it is right
so uh
john from las vegas
the cynthia rice
kenny gill from melbourne australia
yvonne walken suzanne forrest
uh
anita blake
cebu how are you
again isaiah gary how how are you dan
hira
old man ro
old man ray from uh twitch
kevin murphy
helen ludlow jumped again i'm sorry
jeanette howlett from the uk
gary hurts
we're gonna get into all of it
kate friedman from new york's finger
lakes
train of miner from ontario
all right
thank you susan i love you too
very simple
sad though you know
look i get that i have haters
i embrace it
any celebrity does
i get it
lauren ipsum thank you for the five
bucks
i
i have no problem with people hating on
me
i really don't
you want to go on reddit and
go to dabblers anonymous or whatever you
go on hello kate freeman thanks for the
five bucks
fine
knock yourself out
that's what rocks your boat
you know that's what makes you
happy
do it
trash me
i don't care i really don't
don't go on reddit
i know
yes blake craig i read these
i know my moderators
well i know that nikki b doesn't go on
it
i've told them not to
i've asked her not to i can't tell her
what to do but i'm asked to not do
because you know what i don't want to
know
i don't want to know their ridiculous
theories
that i'm a limo driver
substitute teacher or need supervisor
uh
visitation
post office employee you know
and the list goes on
i don't see my kids
the list goes on i don't care
lie about me dad make up stories
and then you have these people
that were once
people i considered friends like this
crying rhyme this guy comes to my show
travels three hours
from his home i guess somewhere in i
don't know where am i gonna dox anybody
but
somewhere
like
let's say orange county i think that's
vague enough
all the way
two hours to a show
and
then
i make him a moderator because i liked
him
then he starts trashing my co-host royce
rice was livid
royce was like i'm gonna i'm gonna go to
this guy's hou i'd be
and i dm'd crying ryan i said dude you
know
take it easy on trashing
you know take it easy on trash with my
friend
you know
then ryan says to me well i guess i
shouldn't be a moderator then i go okay
if that's how you want
all right
amical departure
now he spends his life
on trashing me
every living moment
on trash in me
and this guy has children
but he doesn't care he
seems to dedicate all of his time to me
thank you
uh leslie rambin for the five dollars
i had this guy sean hockey canada
love this guy talk to him all the time
then he goes he becomes a moderator
and gets
all you booted from my chat
because he keeps turning it into
kids mode
turning it off and on
thank you dan haran
i appreciate it thanks for five bucks
he was another friend
i considered a close friend
because we talked and talked and talked
just like i talked to nikki b all the
time that's the kind of friend
thankfully
uh nikki b
is a real friend the true friend and we
are
we have a great relationship
and then royce was a friend
and then we parted ways
not really of any reason other than
he wanted to dedicate his time to his
arcade
but then it was a copyright strike
against me for a video he put on on my
channel when he was the one who was
doing all that he put on that
john
because i did that show with me billy
west and jackie and that was royce's
production and he put it on my website
but then copyright right struck me
because of it and he wasn't going to put
it up
it's just weird you know so you you know
i i get it you know you're gonna
you know you're going to lose friends in
life and that's just how it works
so
now i'll get to what happened
uh
thank you
you've gotten on for the 500 and serve
me and money
thank you
so
then i get the um
yeah see this is the trolls this is what
they do
they make up lies
i'm i'm putting fake review okay
i'm not putting any fake reviews as much
as crying ryan would like to believe so
his ridiculous theories because he's
embedded in my life
he's entrenched with my life
they like to accuse me of having
sock accounts called dumbass and dumbo
and all this other [ __ ]
that has no basis
no basis in reality
it's just
this is what they do
because they have no life
so
as you know i had a gig at mesquite
street
in corpus christi in june
good money
money i could use for my family
hey
my youngest son is 16. i'm still paying
for his child support i'm still paying
for his driver's ed for his s.a.t prep
for his
college counselor
i pay all these bills
yeah my ex pays too
well not the child's poor of course but
she does our part
so
i told my agent
from
golden artists entertainment
to warn
mesquite street and corpus christi
that
my trolls
would do their best
to cancel my gig
my agent
didn't warn them
i get a call from the club manager
and he says
john i don't know what's going on i'm
getting all these
phone calls
threatening
violence towards women
if i
if i let you perform here
and i
inform him
and
say look dude
these are just
10 to 20 losers
who are doing their best to cancel me
don't worry
they don't live in corpus christi
they're not gonna do anything
they're just trying their best
to hurt my to hurt my wallet
so the gig an hour later
cancels
and my agent
from golden artists entertainment
i emailed
the guy who canceled now granted
the guy that canceled told me
was selling so many tickets on saturday
i don't want to cancel it and i guess
any publicity is good publicity i said
yeah don't worry about
an hour later he cancels
so i
email the club manager
and go i can't believe that you're cat
towering cow towing to my haters
why would you do that
it's all i say
just an email like that
my agent
from golden artist entertainment then
text me
stop emailing the club manager
unless you're gonna profusely apologize
you can't make this up
i'm
the one who should apologize
when he
is the one
who canceled me
now
thank you eve got none thank you very
much
i didn't do anything
but my agent from golden artist
entertainment wants me
to apologize
i call
my manager
dante
from golden artist entertainment he's
been on this program and up until
today
he was a friend
and i say
how is this guy texting me to apologize
this club manager
just canceled me
oh well yeah i guess that's not right
i'll i'll reprimand them
watch this
so now we'll cut to yesterday
i i get
i fire that agent
i don't have any reason to call him by
name
the only reason i'll call dante by his
name because he's been on the show
he makes these wonderful
uh uh
videos
against the police brutality in
california against people of color
and i've had him on this show when we
played some of them
i always considered dante your friend i
i don't
never had a problem with him
so
the new agent he gets me
i love this guy
i'll say his name because he's a good
guy
his name is nick
he
because when i asked dante if he does
contracts
do we have a contract with
a mesquite street he goes
no i just do word of mouth
i just have it on cell phone texting you
know
you go really
every other agent i've ever had those
contracts but okay
so when i get nick i go nick do you do
contracts of course john
who doesn't i go well don't they so you
don't he goes all right yeah of course i
do a contract i go okay good
cause i'm gonna i'm gonna promote my gig
at the alameda comedy club
all that i'm saying is true
and can be corroborated with a text
stream
at an email stream
i don't lie
i refuse to
so
my agent
nick
who happens to be
a damn good one
he
gets a contract a sign contract
where
if the club cancels
they have to pay me half
the club gives me 250 to get a plane
ticket
okay
i get the non-refundable
plane ticket from cheaptickets.com
so
apparently
the club alameda comedy club
starts getting calls
inundated with calls and
emails
and
the people
who are writing another troll
see this is i'm going to put it up john
you're 100 online we found your fake
review accounts where you told the club
just admit what happened tickets weren't
selling and they canceled
jesus
jesus
see this is the kind of nonsense let me
block him
that these trolls like to go by
i don't have fake accounts
they could say i do
you have crying ryan who's gonna try and
pretend i do oh look at
i have fans
i have fans
the club had no problem with ticket
sales
mesquite street had no problem with
ticket sales
they don't cancel a gig a month out if
they have bad ticket sales
anyway getting back to the narrative
and the story
i get
a text from my agent nick
who i have no problems with
saying to me
am i going to do my tootsie audition i
go of course
so i
you know i was i did mitosi audition
uh yesterday so i'm sure my trolls will
now be contacting the producers of
tootsie the broadway show
they want me to play the sydney pollock
role
as michael dorsey's agent
so
nick
uh
my agent says to me john um
after you do the audition i gotta talk
i have to talk to you
and i go what
about he doesn't answer because he
probably
doesn't want to upset me
nick's a damn good guy i love the guy
and he's going to have a good career as
an agent because he's meticulous he does
contracts he doesn't do word of mouth
or or a text
so
then i get an email
from dante golden artist entertainment
now i don't see the email at first
but i eventually get it so for the troll
first of all i don't post
other people's texts or emails so i'm
not gonna do that
but i don't see the email until 21
minutes later
i just happen to see dante comes up
dante writes me an email it's been a
pleasure to work with you
but unfortunately i have to drop you
because
the alameda comedy club
got inundated with people
saying that if they had me
they would give
them a one star yelp and google uh
review
dante informed me that
i'm a liability
now i'm paraphrasing i'm not going to
get his email exactly correct so my
apologies dante if i don't exactly get
the wording
correct but he said you know john it's
just
we can't book you
every time he booked you
your trolls
they get you canceled now i'm
at that point i was
i was cool with dante you know okay
this is you know this is his business
but i was mad
very man
that he didn't call me
he's been my friend for three years he's
been on the show a number of times i've
done shows with him and for him
i was a little upset that he didn't call
me first
so i text him
and i said
really dante you don't call me
you email me
to which it responds it it's a legality
that's the way i had to do things
so i said well could you have called me
right after you sent the email i had an
important call
so you're letting go your number one
client at least that's what you told me
a billion times i'm the most famous
client you had so you let me go
but you don't call me you email me
granite i was angry
and i sent them some angry texts
you know
[ __ ] off you know i'm gonna trash on my
show whatever you know because i was mad
and yeah i'll admit i have a bad temper
when it especially when i'm
i'm watching my whole stand-up career
end
i don't know how
anybody
who has a passion
and a love
for what he does
what he or she does
and then to now
have the gigs
get canceled one by one
because
those that hate me
for no reason
never did anything to him i got this
vicky girl i got this fudgsicle
all these anonymous people i've done
nothing to
nothing
you know what if this is really arm
you're choosing the wrong fight john
because i like you
i am the victim here
i didn't do anything
all these trolls who did i hurt
what have i done to them
but they like to
cancel me now
so my gigs are canceled
alameda comedy club
oh this is the best part of it i'm sorry
so
not only
do they breach the contract and cancel
me
not only
do they not offer me the
half of the money
which was in the agreement in the
contract that they signed
they also
have the audacity
to ask my agent for the 250 dollars back
for the flight
okay
i kid you not i have it all on text
from my agent
they asked
for the 250 back prince i'm not gonna
do that to dante as much as i dislike
him right now i'm not gonna dox him
thanks for the two books charm show the
email we'll shut the trolls up
you know what
maybe i'll show it to one person so they
know that it's
a corroborated story
but i'm not going to do that to dante
that's right that's a professional email
just like the text between he and i are
professional
i would not out him
for some of the [ __ ] he wrote me
and some of the [ __ ] i wrote it
so finally
yeah i know it's
a piano creams i don't know how to
change the title there oh i know how to
do it you know
it's really not that important now but
i'll do it anyway
just because i don't want to distract
anybody
um
i do have the minus touch brothers
coming on soon so i don't want to go too
long with the story but i'm getting to
the
juice of it all
but let me just change the date
look
i get it
i do
a political
show
i get it
and it's a lefty show
and i get
that
on this show
i'll alienate
those right wingers
but i won't only alienate them
much like they storm the capitol
to me
they'll just get my gigs canceled
eve got none thanks again come over to
europe surprisingly less cancel culture
here yet
now look you know
this guy
is now he's saying that i have sock
accounts it's just amazing
even if i don't even if i did
would you blame me
let's say i had two or three socket
counts
and i wrote okay let's i'm you know i'm
even getting ahead of myself
so what happens is
i get a hold of dante
and i say
i say uh so what happened
well
you know they got
too many trolls threatening to give them
one star reviews on yelp
so they decided to cancel i go are you
gonna get me the money back
well i don't know if
he says he doesn't even know if i have a
contract
i go
dante
nick has a contract
well i gotta talk to him about it then
give me until one o'clock
then nick
sends me the email it's all documented
on my phone i got it all here
that they want the 250 back
for my non-refundable ticket
now i'm living
so i go on patreon and i
and i write something i say hey guys i
just got canceled hey that that's my
prerogative
okay i let my fans know and my
supporters
know going on
two masks stop attacking
monique i'm not attacking monique i
haven't said a word about her on this
show
don't give a [ __ ]
what she does
she's another friend of mine
i thought
until she decided to
much like everybody else
see there's more money
and not being my friend than there is to
be my friend
but
let her do a thing
i'm not attacking her
i don't text her except saying i thought
we were friends
but for those who don't know she decided
because crying ryan had a text from
three years ago
when a monique had trashed me and i and
i called her a two-faced c-word
because she trashed me and ryan decided
to
send that to monique and that apparently
was enough even though we've been fine
for three years since
that was enough
to get her to trash me after doing my
show so many times and me doing her show
so many times and us having such
splendid conversations
that hurt me
it did
really hurt me
because i really did think we were
friends and if i had uh
uh
mr heyoka you say you don't attack kids
who am i attacking i'm not attacking any
kids
didn't attack anybody's kids
just get the [ __ ] off here you know what
you know somebody blocked this person
i don't attack anybody's kids
anyway
to make this very long story short
the club cancelled they don't plan on
honoring the contract i gave dante a
whole day he said he's gonna try and
handle it by this morning i realized i
had no chance
i texted dante and said well i guess you
know
i guess nothing's gonna be done
so
[ __ ] it so i wrote again on patreon what
had transpired
dante sent me a very angry email
calling me a lot of different things
so now i'm sure he'll be booked on all
the hate shows
but i'm not trashing dante you know he's
got a business to run
he started with the club of course well
you shouldn't have posted that on
patreon and you shouldn't have had your
people start to write bad reviews well
look man
look
first of all i never told them to write
bad reviews and second of all
even if i did
they'd cancel me because they're afraid
of getting bad reviews why can't my fans
do the same why not how is that in any
way
not the same thing
goodbye mad men do you blame kevin from
why am i
podcasting for the cancelled shows
yeah i do blame kevin in some indirect
way
because he is
he's instilling this kind of hatred
towards me
and this hatred is getting me canceled
yeah i do
i do blame him
i do blame these people
so
that's all i could say i'll come back to
it at some point when i have tony
michaels on
but right now we have more important
things to do
and that is
the best
group of people
that i have on the show the three
brothers although we're missing one of
them today
the misalis brothers from midas touch
i can't tell you how grateful
that i am to ben jordy and brett
for the great work that they are doing
to preserve our democracy
so
yeah how are you ben
i'm good john how are you don't let the
haters get you down that's positive
well they just got my gig cancelled you
know that they you know they contacted
the club saying that they're gonna give
him a one star review so the club cow
towered and this is the second
gig in a row that i've gotten canceled
ben and you know how would you feel if
somebody told you you couldn't be a
lawyer anymore
you know it's the uh i i totally get it
but um
you know just keep your head high keep
doing what you're doing and uh
you know your work will uh resonate with
the people
thank you ben and i appreciate the
positive support and
uh where is brett today
brett you know
we're a very lean and nimble operation i
mean
people think that might as touch where
this you know because i would say our
output
is online with major media you know the
productions that we put on the amount of
videos that we have out there
um but it's pretty much me brett and
jordy we rely on a team of
uh i like how you forgot jordy's name
there for a second it happened hey being
the youngest i'm just i'm just lucky you
know as i exist last year yeah and we
have a team of kind of great people who
we work with who come in as consultants
or whatever but we're a lean mean
operation so if three of us are here
that means there's no one man in the
walls
well you know man i really do you know i
know i've had john i was the first one
to have you on but i really do
appreciate all that you guys do and i
hope you know it comes from the bottom
of my heart because
you know we are living in a crazy world
and i'll jump right into it
watching those jan six hearings
i mean guys
i mean just to see
what went in
to planning this insurrection and to see
that donald trump knew
he didn't win
knew there was no fraud ivanka knew
and yet
he continued to push this big lie so he
can make money what did you guys take
away from the hearings
i think the hearings were blockbuster
they exceeded
any expectations that i had
um even going in and my expectations
were
that uh benny thompson liz cheney and
the group were gonna put on some
compelling evidence you know i thought
the first day was a very strong
presentation where they said what the
evidence was going to show you know i
think the witnesses they had there on
the first day were very
intentionally
uh normal people you know and i think
they picked you know a female police
officer who
uh devoted her life to protecting the
capitol building to kind of bring it
home to people how
um
you know just just real this affects
real patriotic americans like this uh
police officer who's trying to defend
the capital then you have the filmmaker
who was in war zones who you know
testified that this was akin to a war
zone but to me
day two
uh from this week was a
blockbuster on top of a blockbuster
where they had five republican witnesses
one by deposition and and the other four
who testified live but these were all
republicans
i know these are not democrats these are
not
you know rhinos you know which
apparently everybody's a rhino other
than donald trump he's the only you know
but these were people who worked
directly with trump these were people at
fox news this was the top republican
election expert
um and all of them you know reiterated
over and over again that there was a
team normal and then there was kind of
trump who was on his own island engaged
in these heinous crimes and um as the
congresswoman who was
leading the hearings yesterday said not
only was this a big lie but this was a
big fraud
and
you know there was a monetary in
everything with donald
is a monetary theft and so he created a
fake
fund called the trump defense fund
didn't exist
raised 250 million dollars for this fund
and we learned things like
uh his
kimberley guilty
uh that she paid herself on january 6th
for the speech that she gave
sixty thousand dollars for the two and a
half minutes speech
or four hundred dollars per second
um to get out the breakdown is
that's the break well that it's what
someone tweeted at me so i hope them
we're good at a lot of things but we're
not good at math it sounds within the
range but you know i i think that brings
home also that these are people these
are these are people who violated our
constitution and who are predatory and
violated the trust and support of of all
americans and their supporters the most
that's the frustrating part is that this
these hearings will wake up
independence they will you know for
people who are like oh everyone's you
know nothing's going to happen i always
they stop the whining
that's not the case i mean you already
see in the new york post for example in
the wall street journal two editorials
that were
basically saying trump wants to be in
2020 let's leave them there you know
grant those are rupert murdoch papers
now rupert murdoch shouldn't get any
credit whatsoever for the disaster that
but
in terms of what he views public opinion
you can tell if he has two of his papers
saying that you know he's trying to you
know you know
take both sides of it believing that
american people are going to come out
against trump at the end of it so that's
my overall view i'll toss it to jay
yeah look man i think the committees my
key take away one word flawless i mean
you can't ask for enough they were
throwing a curveball the other uh the
other day they had to delay it for about
45 minutes but they already had a plan b
in backup and just the execution of it
all after seeing so many you know from
the second impeachment just like these
joke like people almost making a joke of
our court system uh the marjorie taylor
uh green trial just like it was just so
upsetting to see
but now you're looking at this you're
looking at these hearings and the way
it's being executed and the evidence and
the way it's being presented
is just so
flawless it's smart it's well done it's
prepared well and i can't wait for day
three
well that's interesting jordy and um you
know and
and then i'll you know i'll
i'll direct this question i guess to you
because i had i had glenn kirschner on
you know he's a great attorney and
30-year prosecutor he said what is
brilliant geordi is also
that
they did this
televised right
if they would have just indicted trump
before this nobody would have got to see
this
but now everybody gets to see it
do you understand like so he's like
that's why it's genius because then when
the doj
plans to indict
they don't i mean everybody already
knows
all of this stuff do you agree
yeah but
i agree but it is
what should be occurring on a bipartisan
basis
regardless of of it this
what happened on january 6th should not
be a partisan issue
i think there are things that should be
potentially partisan
you know partisan issues but things like
january 6 things like global pandemics
things like 18 year olds walking around
with ar-15s who don't have credit there
are just some things in my own view that
shouldn't be partisan issues
and to me this is a bipartisan committee
in the sense that you have kenzinger and
cheney two republicans on the panel the
fact that all of the witnesses are
republicans but the fact that you have
the
actual gop the the actual formal
political party who has taken away
liz cheney's you know uh platform from
the republican party because she
supported these bipartisan efforts and
because you have the gop
holding press conferences to try to
counter program these hearings the
official
gop judiciary committee account says
like you know is is like [ __ ] tweeting
at the panel saying snooze fest and
things like that and so you know to
answer your question about glenn chris
glenn kushner is a genius yes but we've
always come together
as a country whether it's after 9 11 you
know whether it's you know in a
watergate style here and we've come
together to expose these truths
that's just what we should do
and we shouldn't look at it as holy [ __ ]
that's brilliant we should look at
that's what their job is
that's what they're supposed to do
one of the biggest things too is to make
sure that
you know it's amazing that it's
televised for the historical context of
everything but people are still going to
be in their own silos like if you're
watching fox news coverage you're
getting fox news coverage so we have to
get creative here as content creators
and people who care about the democracy
if you're watching you know this
broadcast right now who are you sharing
you know extended versions extended
clips with from the hearings like in
your own close family friends making
sure that you're penetrating through
those the noise of fox news and all the
[ __ ] that people get fed on such a
daily basis so you know we at midas
media for example we've been live
streaming we got a camera in there in in
the hearings and we have our own footage
on the network where we live stream each
hearing so each one of the dates we're
making sure that we bring up that
footage on our youtube channel the midas
touch youtube channel to make sure that
where at least you know we have this
footage no one could take it away from
us we paid for this footage and we're
going to clip every second that we can
every bombshell moment get that on
youtube get that on tick tock get it on
twitter share with everyone that we can
because at the end of the day you still
have to find that approach to break
through all the noise yep let me just
say kenneth otto thanks for the 20 bucks
john my family
i'm crazy but this is the money i would
spend dining out if i could date right
now so it's like this john i love you
man happy christmas
half a month early brother you make
people happy ah so nice and thank you
benny loco who's a big fan of you guys
hello and you've already got my thank
you brandon shirt on thanks guys
[Laughter]
i
i was planning on wearing a minus touch
shirt but i i wear them all the time
especially the one that says uh
uh it wasn't rigged you just lose it
there you go there you go
but um
the other thing and ben you know yeah
there you go
the other thing that you
touched on which is really important
because i got a
i guess ex friend now you know but he's
a right winger
texted me immediately after the first
hearing
to write me oh
i guess he's drinking a kool-aid wow
it's not even like
the other side it's just all one-sided
and i'm going just like you said ben
there's two republicans on the gen 6
committee
all the witnesses are republicans
what are you talking about there's
there's tons of republicans at these
hearings you know what i mean
remember when the special committee was
being formed
all of kevin mccarthy's requests in
terms of the composition
in terms of what the hearing would look
like
were actually agreed to i think to the
chagrin of a lot of democrats that they
were
going out of their way to reach out to
kevin mccarthy to allow this to happen
and then kevin mccarthy basically after
proposing all of these things and after
getting everything he wanted
um you know then said no we're not going
to be a part of this and you know they
turned it into a partisan thing and you
know you just go back and you listen to
what people like kevin mccarthy said
after january 6. we need to get to the
bottom of this we need to make sure that
everyone's held accountable and then
they go right into their
kind of fascist submissive uh state
which is
you know which has taken the country in
a horrible direction that
they're so
uh
i used the word before submissive but
so obedient to
donald trump
who we see behind the scenes
and we know you know you know
is
is a madman as someone who throws those
most loyal to him
under the bus he actually takes joy
in those who are most obsequious
in destroying those people that like
that fuels him to hurt those closest
to him
the most
and he is not intelligent he's erratic
but what he's good at
is like a magnet
or one of those you know uh
fluorescent lights outside he's a master
at attracting the flies
and the gnats
and then killing them and you know and
and getting more powerful and it's a
very strange
quality
um it's just a very strange thing to see
that in in
in america that
that exists it's like
there's so much great we can do if we
came together as as a country
and built this
ex you know built this built on this
great dream this american promise
but you have someone like that who
literally just throws out hate it's a
constant stream of hate every day and
incompetence
and
i think that it was always in this
country donald trump just made it okay
to
to just be public about the hate be
public about being a white supremacist
they don't seem to have a problem with
that anymore i i had a i had eric
swalwell on and i said you know has the
republican party become the white
supremacist party because yeah pretty
much
i mean
that's kind of like donald trump made it
okay to hate you know well we also know
we talked about this on the midas touch
podcast that the republican party in
miami-dade
um is made up of a significant
contingent of proud boys who actually
sit as the leadership within the
republican party in in miami-dade and
you know i don't think that's unique to
that area that's just what we're seeing
and then when pressed about that marco
rubio replied yeah but democrats have
socialists in their party which i mean
just
not coming in with any facts i mean
confirmed seven proud boys
running the gop in miami-dade and they
pressed marco on it and his response was
to double down essentially
uh eve got none from serbia thanks for
the 250 any opinion on us helping
ukraine in the military budget that's
another thing i don't you know it's
always kind of cool
when you get
like a republican to actually respond to
your tweets
but
adam kinziger tweeted out why hasn't joe
biden talked about ukraine and i said
well adam
maybe joe's smart and is planning behind
the scenes much like obama did when he
was planning the assassination of osama
bin laden
uh maybe he doesn't do his uh you know
his diplomacy on twitter
like a woman guy
and then adam just started going
ballistic going back and forth with me
and to me i'm like
it's kind of cool that i you know that
i'm able to you know
get these like people to come back at me
you know it's such a good point that you
make though john it's like we become so
normalized as a society to think policy
is dictated over twitter
and it shouldn't be it's like it's such
a ridiculous concept that if the
president isn't constantly tweeting out
updates about x y and z doesn't mean
it's not happening behind the scenes and
that's just another symptom of the trump
era that i hope we could get away from
but
it seems like people are clinging to
that as you know if it's not tweeted
it's not happening and i think though
that is something that we do need to
reflect on because to me when i watch
biden's speeches and when i see biden
interviewed even even like a jimmy
kimmel you know i think look
this sounds like a serious sober
president who cares about the issues who
espouses compassion who is clearly older
but who's a sympathetic you know leader
who i'd want to to to run the nation but
what we forget though is really the
power of social media the power of kind
of a tick tock culture
and having to be able to speak in tick
tocks or tweets
or
or instagram posts
and
i think that is a struggle
that biden has right now that the
democratic party has right now it's a
niche we filled
at midas touch you know presenting
ourselves as
we don't we don't even say
you know democrat progressive anymore
you know our main framing is we're
pro-democracy
um and here are fundamental issues like
i said um when it comes to you know 18
year olds not having ar-15s and my
belief that people should have health
care and my belief that january 6 was
bad and my belief when there's a global
pandemic we should try to stop it and my
belief that dr fauci should not be
arrested you know these are very
fundamental beliefs where i want to
bring a broad coalition of people
together and then we can have nuanced
discussions within that but what we what
we've been successful at is conveying
these
complex ideas if you will in
a a way that's palatable in social media
and that's where i think that biden and
the white house though needs to get
better yes because even a jimmy kimmel
appearance where
that's like a 1994 playbook right that's
bill clinton goes on arsenio hall and
plays the saxophone and everyone loves
it in today's day and age a kimmel
appearance and i like kimmel that's not
going to move the needle
it's got to be relentless every day
on social media engaging with the people
explaining to them the issue of gas
prices relentlessly explaining you know
look uh these oil companies are making
record profits
we have more production of oil now than
under the trump administration this is a
price gouging issue and we're trying to
pass bills to stop the price gouging
from taking place yes is inflation high
it is but there are record corporate
profits and we need to make sure that
corporations are held accountable yes
exploiting sensitivities in the markets
that needs to be conveyed better that's
what what midas is is doing but to you
know that ultimately just goes back to
your point though
you know should biden be tweeting more
should biden be out there should he be
doing and i hear presidents should not
be pop stars but remember you know the
role of being the executive and the
commander-in-chief
has a dual purpose there is a ceremonial
role to it which in the past
used to mean
they do the halloween thing and the
and the you know in the christmas lights
and then you know the turkey pardons
right like there is a level of that that
in other countries you have two separate
roles
of of you know the state and the
monarchy sometimes and then a prime
minister who's supposed to be you know
unfortunately in today's day and age
it's it's less of being a pop star
it's more of
communicating directly to the people in
ways they understand and pop stars
are sometimes very good at being able to
communicate messages in ways that relate
to people that's all it's a constant
communication repetition repetition
repetition at the end of the day people
no longer have attention spans and no
longer have good memories so if you're
not constantly hitting that message home
every single day it's going to get
washed out unfortunately
yeah i agree with you both there and i
think that's the democrats always has
been our biggest problem is our
messaging you know
really we should be doing like like all
i see jim jordan now tweeting is about
inflation and gas rises because you know
meanwhile ben
jordy doesn't it drive you crazy gas
prices are ten dollars a gallon in hong
kong nine dollars a gallon in norway
850 in denmark
but yet
the right always want to blame joe biden
for gas prices and they want to blame
joe biden for inflation when inflation
is happening globally
we got to be able to say that why isn't
biden saying that
well here's here's the other kind of
leg you know in the proverbial kind of
you know three-legged stool
analogy you know though is that the
media itself
is
is this is the dynamic you have a
right-wing propaganda channel in fox
which is going to hate on him and then
you have you know your cnns and even
your msnbc's
which are
running the the the high gas price story
they're running with the high inflation
they're not really running with any type
of here are the accomplishments that are
made
here's what biden's done for unions
here's what biden's done for workers
here's the you know the
the reporting on
um uh unemployment being at its lowest
levels under any presidential
administration and
and biden being you know the best job
creator of any president that maybe gets
a second you know a blur you know and
then these media networks focus on
amplifying the jim jordans and so jim
jordan's got two platforms he's got fox
and then he's got the both side-isms of
cnn and msnbc so how do you
how do you break through
when that when that exists and so
structurally what we're trying to do at
minus touch when someone says well what
is your goal what do you want to be
in two to five years
it is to actually be a counter balance
and a check on what like fox news is i i
want us to be a network that promotes
these values which i think transcend
right and left and are really where the
american people are at and they're tired
of the talking head back and forth of
people pretending to be experts who
aren't experts sitting on a panel and
having debates where they just yell at
each other i just think we're beyond
that and i want midas media to be a
network that actually speaks to
americans and speaks with americans
um i i do want to talk to you a little
bit about what you're planning for the
midterms but you know i have to ask you
something ben and i you know
i hope and if if it's if i'm not
supposed to mention this just tell me
but you represented colin kaepernick
didn't you
they do yes
okay
what's going on i mean you know the new
york jets could use a nice backup
quarterback
what's going on has the nfl just said
you know we're banning this guy i mean
he's certainly good enough to play for
the new york [ __ ] jets
well
i'll say i'll say this and leave it at
that one
um
he's he's truly
an incredible person you know yes he's
become you know probably my best friend
like nice someone who
i admire on on every level i mean i work
with a lot of intelligent and smart
clients who are you know business
leaders and philanthropic leaders and
when i tell you that colin is like by
far
you know the most intelligent person
and
with the best instincts that i've met
you know i i i couldn't speak more
strongly
about what what just a great person he
is so his fight for the people
and his care and compassion to do this
work that you know doesn't even get
reported about but almost every day
behind the scenes collins doing
you know spending most of his time
focused on charitable and philanthropic
work be you know behind the scene and
then in terms of you know football he's
been up every day for the past five
years at like 4 a.m in the morning i
know because i talked to him i i know i
i speak in every day and he's training
he's ready to go you know
every person as he's kind of practiced
and and and done these kind of uh
impromptu workouts over the past few
months you know whether it's trainers
other nfl players anybody who's seen him
from a wide spectrum of people who could
say negative things if they want to
they're not under any you know
requirements that they speak you know
they've all said that he could be a
starter immediately that he definitely
deserves to be you know in the league
and so i could only speak to one
the colin i know as a great person and
two what experts say about him because
i'm a lot of things but my eye for who's
a great football player i i wouldn't be
picked first on the flag football
i know i was just curious if he's got a
chance to play again and it's not why
oh i think um you know he's he's waiting
and hoping that door can open and he's
ready to walk right through because
here's the thing ben and and then i'll
get off this because i didn't want to
make you uncomfortable i just i mean
there's no no one no one come no
all right because because i was just
thinking about it and i was i was like
god i gotta ask ben about colin because
i love colin kaepernick and i'll tell
you what he was
he was the first
to
let the world know
what's going on with police
brutality towards people of color and
granted a lot of people got pissed off
at him for taking that knee but guess
what
he was the first he was the one to let
everybody know and i think he was the
innovator for that and he was proven
unfortunately to be correct after what
happened to george floyd so to me
colin kaepernick's a hero
i couldn't agree more and you know
sometimes when you believe in something
yet have to sacrifice everything you
have to sacrifice everything it
shouldn't you know you have to be
willing to
you know sometimes and you have to be
able to
you know put it on the you know put it
all on the line and in terms of you know
what what we do at kind of might as
touch um you know building
this entity you know building this kind
of multi-prong vehicle for pro-democracy
there's a lot of other things
you know whether you know i mean brett
is a two-time emmy award-winning editor
and brett could probably get any job in
the film industry right now you know
make a huge amount of money and
not have to deal with the hateful emails
and the
you know and the [ __ ] every day you
know jordy had a great marketing job in
new york and was doing just fine
um you know and and my law practice you
know was a thriving practice where i
would represent lots of clients you know
and i pretty much have you know
made it really where i just work with
colin and then i do midas touch work at
this point and i do a handful of other
cases but you know the ethos of
really trying to sacrifice um and make a
difference in this world and set an
example for others is something that i
you know truly believe in and it's why
when we started midas touch right away
knowing we'd get some hate
truthfully not knowing the level and
amount of
you know
you know what
what it means when you get you know
a relentless barrage of anti-semitic
comments and death threats on a fairly
frequent basis that occurs but you kind
of manage to silence that out and you
manage to say i want people to know who
we are because the example we want to
set for everybody who identifies as
being part of the midas mighty group is
that you can do it too and that we can't
look for superheroes you have to be the
superhero in this story about democracy
and so we just try to set that example
of
look this is what we're doing every day
this is the type of work we're doing
every day and i promise you
can do this also in your own way if that
means you are a chef then let's try to
cook for people and inspire them to vote
if you're an educator let's educate
people and come up with pamphlets if
you're an artist let's let's draw
pictures you know if you're a great
public speaker let's do this if you
whatever your talent is there's a place
for you in this fight
thanks uh uh thank you uh lulu girl for
the two bucks yay ben and jordy they're
great hallelujah
uh listen um
what are you planning because now we got
we got the val dummies is going against
a little marco right um
and you know i mean i know that nicki
freed i hope
takes you know beats chris because
because i'd love to see her go against
uh
uh
uh desantis so
so what are you guys doing right now on
the ground to support
um
you know all up sorry until my son is
texting me because i gotta i get i have
to drive him to team team
the suicide teen line because he's he's
he's
destined to go to harvard that's all he
wants to do is go to harvard so he's all
straight a's ap courses and uh
so he's just texting me he's got to
drive him uh anyway so what are you guys
doing on the ground
there's a lot that we're doing a lot
that's going to be rolled out over the
kind of coming weeks and months i don't
want to give away
the full strategy of what we tuned
it's kind of like giving away the
playbook so that
people can you know you know can know
what's coming but you know i'll say this
like the videos that we've put out
already you know in a short period of
time if a video that we put out doesn't
get
like a million views um
we don't view that video as being you
know a viral success and so it's a
pretty high standard it's kind of like
your son trying to set the harvard
standard that's kind of like our our
video standard is each video needs to
get into harvard to have the right
impact but you know we you know it's
funny
i'm sorry you know what's funny man
sorry forgotten
um
my daughter was valedictorian
of calabasas high school
now my son oscar he wants to beat her
great
so
god bless sibling rivalry which is why i
thought i thought we were competitive
ben i thought we were competitive
siblings
i never tried
and if i applied to harvard uh they
would probably look at me
and say what do you wait
what college did you go to so i went to
gw undergrad and i went to georgetown
law nice look at you fancy fancy wow
that's really
law school in 2010
which is uh hard to imagine that i've
been a lawyer now for 12 years
genius geez okay so so
so on the ground you don't want to tell
this yet because you're just going to
let it happen no no i mean look you've
seen some of the ads that we've done so
right after the leaked opinion uh
overturning roe v wade
uh took place we did a gop handmaid's
tale i saw it i love that it's got about
four million views i played that about
three times on this show yeah that's it
thank you it's a really strong ad we
just did an ad on herschel walker
fumbles and we did it with like nfl
blitz style and we showed each time he
fumbles um in all of the mistakes he's
made um
you know we're going to be focused on
the
you know competitive races you know we
don't want to waste time and resources
on right you know on
just kind of splashy pr things that may
not actually have an impact on the
ground we always work closely and in
concert with people on the ground who
are in the state and so we never just
insinuate ourselves in a state and say
we're here we're might as touch you know
our
videos we always want to make sure that
we fill a specific niche and slice
that's helpful and i'll give you an
example in georgia in 2020 2021 stacy
abrams and her group was focused in the
urban areas
but there were not resources on door
knocking in the suburban areas that
tended to tilt uh in favor of trump or
would tilt in favor of
the republican gop candidates lochler
leffler and perdue and the runoff so we
focused our door knocking efforts on
trump areas nice in suburban georgia and
not there um with full ppe for an end a
living wage and if you want to look up
what the minimum wage in georgia is it's
definitely not a living wage
but we paid our people a significant
living wage i hate the term living wage
too because it should be more than just
living
[Music]
but we did a door knocking campaign
there that actually according to the
data that we had
we know in the areas we were at about a
one to two percent swing
um
that you know that decreased the trump
vote even though purdue and lafleur
still won in those areas it took their
percentages down about a point and a
half so those are the types of efforts
that we're going to roll out whether
it's with the billboards whether it's
where we're targeting our actual um you
know ads themselves you know we remember
the splashy ad we did
about uh the grinches who stole georgia
with
ren perdue was a cartoon one we have
some ideas around coming up with one of
those for one of the candidates um
who
i don't want to give away
but
you know we're going to continue this
digital operation which i think is first
class if anyone follows midas you know
the level the
quantity and quality
of the work that goes out every day i
mean i mean this there's more output
digital from midas with me brett and
jordy and our kind of small network of
affiliates and i think are of any
mainstream media if you just look at the
output that's being done every day
and we're just going to keep educating
people the most important thing that we
can do
is really empower a coalition of people
though who we can then activate at the
right times whether it's through text
message campaigns whether it's through
their local groups to you know write the
postcards um but it's it's a people
driven movement
that is on the pack side of what we do
is all
pretty much small donor based you know
the average contributions like 20 bucks
you know from people we've never had one
instance in the history of midas um and
jordy correct me if i'm wrong but i
can't recall a single one where a midas
donor has been like i wish you would
have done that why did you do this you
know like everyone is thrilled about
um you know the the movement and
everyone's really happy about jordi and
his cute face
hi kelly
um during the georgia let me just build
on that real quick man uh during the
georgia runoffs uh the midas mighty
the amazing group of followers who
follow midas touch they sent seven
million
text messages
so to just have that base and that was a
year and a half ago at this point
to be able to activate them and have
them take to
just preserving our democracy in in such
an efficient way i mean
i can't thank them enough we owe them
everything
so um you guys have a lot of shows on
your network i know you have uh texas
paul who i love
and you also have the tony of the tony
michaels podcast so i i i asked them to
join you to say hi
oh
howdy let's go hey hey
hey hey how's it going fellas
i want to say this about uh tony and
gabe
so we've been hosting
uh our own stream on the minus media
network on youtube where we've been
streaming the jan sixth hearings which
is one of the top streams i think the
last one got over 100
when you aggregated across facebook and
youtube the two places it's over about
250 000
close to 300 000 viewers who just
watched boom by the way
uh
and tony and gabe have hosted it they've
done an incredible job i mean the pr the
the people who are
you know in from network television who
i know just through the entertainment
law work that i do who call me and say
that's a real good production value and
a good facility
that's the first time i'm hearing that
yeah this is that's good to hear yeah
ben likes to save his compliments i
don't think he hasn't been about six and
a half years so
when he gives one out i mean it's it's
really good well that's good that's good
so
so you know i
let me ask all you guys i'll start with
ben because he's the first one that's
that's next to me and then we'll go
around the horn
ben how you know how do you think that
we're gonna do in the midterms
um i don't think the story's been
written yet i i don't you know i i'd
love to be like we're gonna [ __ ] win
i'm so optimistic or i tell you
truthfully like oh we're [ __ ] you know
it's it's really neither
you know
here's what's happening right now
um the jan sixth hearings
while
they are
should not be political they will have a
political uh implication based on you
know the outcome and how it goes we also
know that the supreme court any minute
now while we're recording this could
happen could actually release the actual
opinion overturning roe v wade and we
know how
one just devastating from a policy that
would be you know taking away a woman's
right to choose but from a public policy
and political standpoint we also know
that the country is by and large in
significant majorities does not support
overturning roe v wade we also know the
supreme court is going to be
issuing another opinion further
expanding the almost absolute right of
an individual to bear arms unfettered
without any regulations and there's a
case in new york that was appealed from
the second circuit where the supreme
court's likely to expand that as well
and so we have this moving political
landscape right now
where
any one of these issues alone
could lead to kind of a tsunami you know
one way or another that changes the
outcome of of this election but what
people need to know is that this
republican party is no longer the party
of small government if they ever were
this is a party that wants to get inside
your home that wants to tell you what
religion you should practice they want
to tell
you what you should do with your uterus
and how we make these decisions for you
primarily male governors republican male
governors want to make those decisions
for you and not your doctors they want
to retaliate against corporations if the
corporations want to reflect diversity
within their corporation because
corporations employ people who are
different races they employ lgbtq plus
from so corporations want to be decent
to their employees and by projecting
views that are tolerant
of people
these republican governors are
retaliating against businesses and
finding businesses and not letting
businesses operate in their states and
so you have all of these things which i
hope will be reaching a sliver
of this independent population and
saying you know and here's just the one
thing i want to say too republicans have
elected by and large in the primaries
the most radical
and or batshit crazy candidates
whether it's in the districts so like
where they could have elected probably
someone who would have won
in pennsylvania you get dr oz who's a
guy from new jersey and turkey who
doesn't know [ __ ] about the state of
pennsylvania and everything the guy says
is a fumble too you know he wants to
speak out against illegal immigration
and yet his company you know was finding
the highest record find in the history
you know for for whatever he wants to
talk out you know on the one hand he
wants to arrest dr fauci and then there
are video clips of him basically saying
you need to wear masks and all this we
just get these ridiculous candidates you
get a candidate in ohio like jd vance
who's a silicon valley san francisco
peter thiel you know funded rich kid in
in ohio which values like workers you
know and so they've picked really bad
candidates yeah republicans so that also
gives me a level of optimism if we could
just stay united and stop attacking each
other and stop with the defeatist
attitude i'm confident they're you know
we're in a position to definitely hold
the senate definitely hold the senate if
we can you know not be defeatist and
then the house is going to be close with
all of the gerrymandering it's really
problematic but if we can basically make
in a generic poll
you know the democratic view more in
line with where the country is and get
the voters out there we'll win and i'll
build on ben's point sj and then we
gotta actually jump for planet call
otherwise brett's gonna just murder us
uh if the doom and gloom democrats could
just get out of their own way in this
upcoming in these next six months it's
so important because all you see every
single day is just dems attacking dems
and all of a sudden on the right not all
of a sudden but you look on the right
they're all united and so just exactly
what ben's point we have to stick now is
the time to stick together here yeah man
okay like like i don't i don't care who
comes out of the primaries for a
democrat i'm supporting that democrat to
win the election no matter what and
that's the attitude that you need you
can't say oh my candidate didn't come
out of the primary i'm not voting no
stop
don't do that we need you now we need
you more than ever don't give up these
next six months are crucial
thank you man thank you so much
jordy thank you i love you guys and you
know and get my best of bread okay
absolutely we will here again everybody
make sure you're subscribed to the midas
touch youtube channel so you can watch
all of our jan sixth hearing coverage is
hosted by tony and gabe come check it
out subscribe there and subscribe to the
midas touch podcast make sure you're
following might as touch across all
platforms all right thanks again guys
please good to see you fellas good to
see you good seeing you later pals bye
all right the great ben
and jordi
myself thank you betty loco for the five
bucks keep your religion out of my
politics and keep the politics out of my
uterus
and uh lulu girl also did a super chat i
want to find hers and that was uh the
hearings have been political all the
testimonies
have been republicans
which is that is the great part about
the hearings isn't it guys they're
supposed to be politicized it is a
political process i mean the republicans
chose this they had the they had the
ability to uh to go with a non-biased
separate commission like a 911 style
commission that's not what they wanted
they wanted a political commission they
wanted a political committee that's what
they wanted that's what they got so
reap what you sow back to your question
that ben and jordi asked there about the
midterms
um
here's the thing and i've said this many
times on our show
81 million people did not vote for joe
biden
there is a hefty amount of that 81
million people that voted against trump
and i think that coalition is building
so it is absolutely it is up to you
folks out there who are listening of
whether you vote or not rather you take
the politic politicization of these
issues seriously or not because the
policies that are beyond
these uh these
hearings or um some of these candidates
that we see ben was very nice and
calling them batshit crazy these people
are absolute [ __ ] lunatics they're
absolute [ __ ] lunatics and if we if
we don't take that seriously then then
we're screwed but here's what i'll
here's what i'll tell you here's what
you should be doing when you're talking
to people in person now on text message
your friends your family and your
community centers and your churches your
schools wherever you're at wherever your
belly-to-belly people you should ask
them because they're always going to
bring up gas prices and inflation you
should say are you going to let the
people who grifted 250 million dollars
away from their supporters and spend it
on [ __ ] like kimberly guilfoyle giving a
two and a half minute introduction
you're gonna trust those people with gas
prices you're gonna trust those people
with our [ __ ] economy you're gonna
trust the people who almost destroyed
our country with a pandemic because they
couldn't they couldn't [ __ ] find
their head or their ass
in their response you're going to let
them run our economy now you're going to
let them
figure out our gas prices these are the
people you want i don't think so i don't
think so i wouldn't elect donald trump
or anyone who is who he supports are
supported by him
to [ __ ] dog catcher and that is the
the main crux of this is we have to get
out in front and we have to be engaged
right it's not just about your vote it's
about making sure that that 81 million
whatever that coalition is and whatever
is building out there against this
anti-trumpism right because that's what
we have to be we have to be against
fascism because it's going to destroy
our country it'll destroy our democracy
if we aren't careful
so that that coalition of 81 million
people they have to get off their asses
and they have to engage like they did in
2020
despite of a pandemic because they knew
the threat because the threat is still
there and it's and this is the most
important election
and the next one will be the most
important election and the next one will
be the most important election because
here's the fact about these fascists
they're not going to stop they're not
going to quit they're not going to try
to stop taking your [ __ ] liberty
taking your [ __ ] rights away they're
not going to stop
you don't really how many gigs away from
you well that is true that is true i
mean this is they are relentless in
their action and they will not stop
until they get exactly what they want um
so that's my answer to the question
about the midterm is it's up to you it's
up to you and i think people are
motivated enough um to get out there and
vote and they know the stakes they know
what's happening especially when we see
the evidence that we're going to see
from the january 6 hearings we see the
evidence
um
when when this decision comes down from
roe v wade that that's exactly what they
want to do is they want to take your
[ __ ] liberty away from you that's
been their goal the whole time uh
evidence in in some of their
capitulating back and forth about easy
common sense gun safety
even common sense gun safety when they
when they do the back doors and porno
[ __ ] it's very obvious what they're
trying to do
and i think people get it i think people
get it it's just a matter of can we get
them engaged and can we get can you get
your family and friends ready to make
sure that they're pro-democracy and they
do something about it that's the thing
gabe
yeah i think um
you know or in 2020 and 2021 um as we've
gone into 2022 like there are things
that you're you're seeing changes that
are happening on a person-to-person
level i think one of the big ones is
people
are beginning to
identify and understand their own
self-worth and their value right you see
people that are unionizing at different
companies you see people saying you know
what i actually don't deserve to be
treated like this in my workplace i'm
going to look for another job you see
these fascists that are in leadership
positions within the republican party
who are saying you know i want to give
more access to guns i won't do anything
to protect your children i want to put
my politics you know
uh to control women's rights of what
they want to do with their own body
their um
you know don't want to protect people at
the gas pump they want to make sure that
children don't have access to a baby
formula you know like the the republican
party is very much
um
uh while they are able to unite on a
common goal right which is primarily
around hatred they
they just have the fake outrage and that
fake outrage is what a lot of people
cling to right i get really upset at
this and so that's what i'm going for
and that's we have a clear vision and i
think you know jordy brought up a good
point about like how the right is very
aligned and the left isn't
and i think as these things begin to be
more apparent and people begin to kind
of open their eyes about what the
republican party is actually doing or
what they're getting away with in terms
of passing legislation or rather the
lack of passing legislation by inaction
um or um you know um complacency by just
kind of standing around and then just
letting things happen
um they
i think people are beginning to realize
and will will move themselves forward
to the polls and i agree with tony 81
million people you know we're not a cult
we didn't all vote for joe biden wave
our flags and wear our joe biden boxers
to the polls right what we did was we
voted against a guy who was leading the
country into a [ __ ] black hole and we
saw it happen during the pandemic and
after for a lack of leadership and a
lack of responsibility as he said i
don't
i don't take responsibility it's not my
fault
and i think that's what ultimately
people are pushing away from and as
these things begin to be more
on the public
people will begin to vote against that
and i'm i'm optimistic
in how the midterms will go i don't know
if like oh it'll go a blue wave or it'll
be kind of a a small like blue tide or
something
but i do hope in the next
five months that we have before the
midterms that we're able to kind of
um
come together and build
this this group this party um and find
common goals and common
um
topics that we want to address so that
we can we can we can be aligned you know
um more so than the right which is on
you know [ __ ] topics and [ __ ]
fake outrage and what have you um
because one party actually does help
people right you look at republicans and
you see it's a negative growth rate that
happens under republican administrations
and then democrats have to come in and
actually fix
and work to develop programs and social
programs and incentives to actually
uh counteract and actually create growth
for the constituents and for the people
that the republicans promised to help
out
so um you know again i don't know if
it's gonna go one way or the other it's
still you know like ben said really
early in the game but i do feel like a
lot of the stuff that's being brought up
whether it's through midas touch our
show or others you know shedding light
on these topics and making an everyday
conversation i think
uh we can make a difference to to
actually move it
um
to an actual potential blue wave i hope
so sunflower dragon thanks for the five
bucks hi guys sorry you had a rough time
john i can't stand cruel people what i
jim larrison thanks for 10 bucks amazing
show john not sure if you already talked
to the about the loss in my congressman
sean castle's family
he is a great guest an amazing person
and thoughts and praise well do you do
you guys know what happened i love
showing i i haven't heard i don't i
haven't heard
uh somebody i guess is saying my mom
just said what happened to his daughter
could somebody tell me what's going on
here because he's been a guest on the
show a number of times blake craig
thanks for the five bucks any of you
questions of the guy in the red hat can
you define fascism please i can't define
what fascism is i i the blueprint for
american fascism is trumpism which is
um fascism in ism in a manga hat but the
other blueprint that's going on right in
front of us is in florida uh what a what
a what fascism is it's normally led by a
dictator or someone who wants to be a
dictator the other thing too is they use
violence and they use uh
criticism against their against their
opposition
you know i don't know it would be like
if um
like if
a dictator or a wannabe dictator
would lose an election tony hold on a
second tony
this is really sad sean caston's 17 year
old daughter was found
dead at her home oh no it was
unresponsive oh i'm sorry my god my
heart goes out to sean and his family oh
god that's freaking sad
yeah
uh uh i don't know sean he's an illinois
congressman i guess yeah he's a damn
great guy he's all about climate change
and
couldn't be a nicer guest i'm so sad for
him
so i i know this term has become a
cliche but my thoughts and prayers
really do go out to his family
uh sunflower dragon fascism of
authoritarian ultra-nationalism
characters
uh
characterized by dictator
dictator allele i can't say it right now
a dictatorial power forcible suppression
of opposition and that is where we're
headed
well again the blueprint the blueprint
is the blueprint is florida with ron
desantis i mean their practice run was
trump and let me let me give an example
what fascism might look like it might be
a guy who runs for president who loses
obviously loses um he spreads lies to
get his
to get his supporters frothed up into a
a violent rage and he uses systems of
government to try to take power where he
does not have power um what would also
be very fascist is a violent siege
on what would be the certification of
result to try to overturn an election so
that you had dictorial power to just to
make yourself
immune from prosecutions now in florida
the the the clear
the clear and concise measure that ron
desantis is trying to use to control
commerce in florida and uh jordi and i
think ben were talking about it earlier
where they're trying to you know ban
disney and make deals to ban math books
with companies where they're trying to
control commerce that's another sign
of of fascism where they're trying to
control commerce right um and not just
not just commerce based on commerce
alone and and what regulation may mean
ideology with the ideology of the
commerce so disney takes a stance and
ron desantis says you can't be a company
no more because you don't believe what i
believe that's that's fascism the other
the other example of fascism is the the
absolute hugging of nationalism right
when a country spirals into fascism it
gets this nationalism type taste and we
see that more and more with just with
marjorie taylor green saying she's a
christian nationalist there's a video of
her saying you shouldn't be afraid of
christian nationalism we should embrace
christian nationalism these people are
[ __ ] nazis ron desantis said ban
disney and all of a sudden his
supporters run to disney and are waving
nazi flags let's go brandon nazis
and he didn't say a thing not a word
and the reason why is because there's
one thing that fascists know is they
don't want to piss off their most
violent supporters that's one thing they
do yeah and as uh
as blake craig says thanks for five
bucks fascism is generally a merger
between the public and private sectors
with an
authoritarian strong man in charge no
corporate money in politics
you know
that yeah that's the problem is this
canceled freaking you know i mean
he's trying to cancel freaking mickey
mouse hey let me just read an ad and
then i want to talk to you guys about
lauren
uh our partners at betonline.ag
continued to be the number one source
for all your betting needs and sports
info find all of the latest odds news
and sports developments including this
year's nba finals the nhl
hockey conference finals major league
baseball scores and the all the latest
fighting news and even next season's
early nfl futures but online.ag is you
continue source for all your sporting
wagering information from live betting
to playoffs esports and more head to the
website or use your mobile devices on
today to receive your 50 welcome models
on your first deposit just use our promo
code clns50 that cl and s50 to get the
uh bonus and get into the action bet
online that ag weather game starts and
now back to the show with the great um
tony and gabe um
tony you
told me on this on the phone
this morning this groundbreaking news so
why don't you tell us all again i
couldn't believe this yeah well you you
you remember the um
the the ass mohawk that the butt crack
mohawk that was madison gothard remember
this the the video where he was humping
his cousin's face yeah so that group
that was uh
putting out that information about
madison gotham which
ultimately i don't know if that led to
him losing his primary and i guess you
could say it had something to do with it
i mean that was the aim of it at least
it was political um you know a lot of
people get you know oh don't be
political [ __ ] be political that's
what i say be political politicize this
issue if you don't want these fascist
and these these let's go brandon nazis i
have power of our government we have to
politicize this stuff um so so that got
politicized and that group um is kind of
given a little bit of credit for taking
down minus and katherine i guess you'd
say so the same group has opened up a
new kind of twitter account i believe
and i think it's just a twitter account
and they gave it it's the same
organization the yeah yeah which is bad
records
what is it uh muckrucker yeah
yeah now they've opened up a twitter
account called fire bobert and they've
been they've been releasing some news
there was a daily mail article
where they had done a referral against
um some campaign finance laws and some
other uh tax liens that lauren bobert
has against her business which is called
um i'm a dumb [ __ ] and i own guns or
something i don't know i know some about
guns and burgers or something or or i
know diarrhea sliders they give you
diarrhea i'm not really sure what
they'll but this morning this morning um
this group along with another account
lincoln watchman
um they dropped some
uh a memo and it appears that the
evidence shows you know that they have
collected that lauren bobert um has had
two abortions um and also and also taken
it seems like um and i don't know
exactly where this is tracked down but
this is verified with the hundred i
think it was 125 000
from ted cruz
um to lauren bobert as when she started
her congressional campaign um so it
seems as if ted cruz
uh we have him to blame for lauren
lauren bobert being a congresswoman in
the first place um with him now is there
anything
i mean tony is there any chance that
one of these abortions was ted cruz's
baby oh i i don't know i guess that's a
good question to ask i have no idea
here's the thing here i want
i believe in the woman's right to have
an abortion i believe i believe i
believe in the woman's right to actually
sell sex to anyone they want i believe
sex work is work i actually do not and
i believe that lauren bobert is trying
her damnedest in this country to take
away that right from other people yeah
and that is why that is why we have to
we have to show
her constituents right because that's
what's at stake here really is lauren
bobert can be lauren bobert all she
wants she can go to rallies and say all
kinds of racist stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] into
a microphone she can have some kind of
[ __ ] diarrhea slider restaurant in in
in shotgun colorado or whatever the [ __ ]
it is where the [ __ ] whatever [ __ ] she
wants to do she has freedom to do that
kind of [ __ ] in this country you have
the freedom to be [ __ ] dumb in this
country that is one freedom you have
but when you're a congressperson when
you're a congressperson and you're
pushing your personal beliefs your
religion on other people and you're
using your religious dogma to hide your
fascism and try
and try to legislate other people's
rights away from them because that is
one thing that we haven't done in this
country a lot is take away we've given
people rights or we didn't give them in
the first place right and we've and over
time we've gotten people more rights and
we need to get to equality and equity as
soon as we can but democracy is hard
but lauren beaubert those constituents
in colorado whoever the [ __ ] is is uh
has the ability to vote for her on the
ballot or vote against her on the ballot
deserve to know
how she enacts
the policies that she says she wants to
legislate it's very similar to the fact
if if if a certain politician had a
certain stance stance on taxes and they
were doing the exact opposite of what
the [ __ ] they were saying if they were
had a certain tax or certain stance on
public funds and people receiving public
funds and they were receiving public
funds in the way that they discouraged
so
i am not [ __ ] sex shaming anyone i
actually wish lauren bobert would go be
a sex worker that would be fantastic i
think that's great i think i think
lauren bobert is good-looking enough she
could be a sex worker the rest rest of
her life
and she may be very successful at it and
she should have the she should have the
right to choose her health care based on
what her needs are regardless of her job
i just don't want her to be a [ __ ]
congress person telling everyone else
what the [ __ ] to do especially when the
things that she's telling people they
don't have the right to do she's been
doing them and and that that is the most
important thing here is that yes is it
politicized of course it is because
she's a [ __ ] politician that's how it
works when you're in public life that's
how it works when you are trying to
legislate other people's rights away
there is no need for anyone in average
american life to have to disclose their
medical history
but when you when you are trying to
[ __ ] take away someone's bodily
autonomy but you want that right for
yourself this it's me not we [ __ ] this
this it's all about me and not about the
rest of the people that fascist style of
politics needs to stop and yes we have
to go at this everyone keeps complaining
oh democrats need to punch back they
need to hit hard they need a bots that's
what this looks like that's what this
looks like is is hitting back hard
because
believe you me believe you me if there
was any evidence out there of a democrat
doing the exact opposite of what they
were saying in policies it doesn't
matter what the [ __ ] it is doesn't
matter how vile the republicans would
point it out and they would win on it
yep so
um i don't know about the constituents
in colorado but i think they deserve to
know
where
lauren bobert stands personally about
herself on the things she's trying to
push legislation for that's what i mean
even even outs like you know keeping
those things aside like we have to
remember that in in this memo or in this
press release they also revealed that 75
000 dollars were donated in an uh and
undisclosed
from ted cruz to beau bridge and he
disclosed the donation until it was
cruz's federal election commission that
uh filings that contradicted her filings
so the other thing too is like this is
also not
news right in the sense of like this is
not a brand new kind of behavior she's
done this before we've seen her use
donor money to pay off taxes restaurant
rent uh she had a tax lien that was
twenty thousand dollars um she you know
miscalculated her her um
her mileage and it you know her initial
readings were
ballooned in the effect of what it
really should be she lied about it she
lied about it to get you know to get the
write off to get the return so she could
pay off the like there's all these
different things you know she still owes
money to her employees back pay she
threatened uh
them if they protested you know you've
got her her husband you know um the guy
who
showed his dick to
lauren beaubert and others when they
were minors
now he has a job with someone right and
now he's got this consulting contract
for an oil and gas company that's over
450 000 a year but he doesn't have any
consulting experience that seems kind of
funny when she didn't she voted not to
hold gas companies accountable to the
right right it's almost like there was a
bit of um
just a conflict of interest almost right
you know but i mean like again you know
this is someone that people in colorado
have to ask themselves do i want this
person as my representative right is
this person doing it i mean even before
all this news came out
that people from her town were already
getting fed up because the pattern that
she was showing was one of someone
seeking celebrity status not actually
doing what she was supposed to be doing
someone who was doing interviews and
going on tv hold on get some flower
dragon thing with two bucks ted cruz was
the father proved me wrong
i i don't i don't know that i don't know
that well actually i don't that's it i
mean they are connected we don't know we
know that based on this press release
it's the it's a coke
family friend member or something like
that what's the website that they cite
because again this is not our research
this is right so the american yeah the
american muckrakers pack um announced
that they had found
paid escort or lauren bober being a paid
escort and the clients met through
sugardaddymeat.com
i mean again it's hard to parody these
people because you would think that she
would say some of this [ __ ] about aoc
right like you could see this [ __ ]
coming out of lo and behold
about aoc and the reason why is because
it's projection right like she she kind
of said this [ __ ] about a representative
omar i mean
so much so that she's having she's
having sex with her brother and all
kinds of [ __ ] right like she was saying
this [ __ ] about her about her opponents
you know her opponents which you know
are her her enemy because she's a
[ __ ] racist but i mean that's that's
the point the point is is that you need
to know who this [ __ ] person is
because she is not who she says she is
she is not i mean it would be one thing
if lauren bobert's like yeah i i want to
get rid of abortion because i've i've
had two of them and here's my story
because there's a lot of people who have
had those stories and and honestly if
you have a pro-life stance whatever that
may be i mean i may vehemently disagree
with it but you have to you have that
right to have it but what you don't have
in this country is the right to run for
political office take away other [ __ ]
women's rights that you want to have for
yourself
she wants to obtain these rights and
hold these rights and as far as other
controversies the other controversy is
with her business
where
she owes back taxes she has tax liens
because what she was doing she was
paying her employees and she wasn't
paying the state the employment tax
on that money so she has a tax lien
against her business apparently with the
state and because she hasn't paid her
that money for her employees are
employed their employees haven't
received any kind of tax benefit
that they were supposed to receive
because of that so they've actually
heard employees have kind of been left
out in a cold in a few instances here um
where they're kind of in a back and
forth with the department of labor
whatever
i'm not sure if that's what it's called
in colorado but that's what it would be
called in most states department of
labor
and taxation so they're so they're
working out that employment tax um with
her because she's uh apparently has not
been paying that so there's a lot of
things about lauren beaubert that is are
questionable but the things that are
most questionable are that she doesn't
do what she tells you to do she tells
you to [ __ ] party
exactly exactly it's
you know it's it's the party of
hypocrites i mean
look miss mcconnell barack obama should
not be allowed to
to uh appoint the supreme court
treacherous in his last year of his
presidency right and then he appoints
and then he's okay with freaking amy
coney barrett getting in right rams it
down our throat ramsay yeah i mean it is
you know what was going on right
was being sent in yep what dave
constantly are hypocrites he's [ __ ]
[ __ ] i can't stand them that's why we
need to politicize everything we have to
politicize it and everyone you know
democrats have always shied away from
that but i don't i don't give a [ __ ] we
have to politicize every single issue i
don't care if it's abortion guns health
care uh education uh social security uh
welfare
whatever it is we have to politicize it
at every measure and every at every turn
because listen
your [ __ ] way of life is at stake
here if these [ __ ] fascists take over
if you just look at florida and what ron
desantis is trying to do in a lot of
cases this is just a blueprint of what
they want to do to the rest of the
country because roe v wade is going to
be overturned it's going to be
overturned but they're not going to stop
there they're not going to go oh yeah we
won now we can quit they're going what
they're going to try to do as soon as
it's done you're going to see them on
fox news oan on all the right wing talk
shows and they're going to say our next
step is to go out there and make sure
blue states can't
allow abortion that's what they're going
to say blue states can't allow abortion
that's what they're going to try to do
is start going after those those states
that are allowing women to have bodily
autonomy because now you have in
different states you have different
classes of citizenship depending on your
on whether you can get [ __ ] pregnant
or not um so that that is what's gonna
happen here is they're gonna move
forward for the next step because
they've always said if we just overturn
roe v wade that'll be great but that's
not where they're gonna stop right and
they're not gonna stop just at women's
bodily autonomy they're going to stop at
trans people's bodies autonomy lgbtq all
gay uh lesbian trans people they're
gonna they're gonna tell men what they
can and can't [ __ ] do they're already
trying to do it they're already saying
that in in oklahoma there's [ __ ]
wackadoo saying that life begins at a
boner
not not i'm dead serious i mean they're
not so many [ __ ] words but that's
what they're saying is an erection is
life it's [ __ ] bonkers and ridiculous
which means they're gonna ban condoms so
all you trumped up white guys out there
that want to jack off with condoms on in
your mom's basement or if you had a
chance to [ __ ] a girl and you want to
[ __ ] her with a condom you might want to
rethink who you're supporting yeah elon
musk you know crypto [ __ ] i mean yeah
you look at arizona and you've got the
guy who's running blake masters he's the
one who has proposed this idea of
banning condoms right which means
they're like well i guess we're have to
have forced births which again you know
these people these republicans well of
course you know the republicans the you
know these people in power will always
find their way to travel to another
state or do whatever to get their uh
their mistress and abortion but that you
know obviously won't you know extend the
same courtesy
to any of the constituents who might
fall within that same thing or
accidentally get pregnant with their
partner whatever it might be like these
are the people again that are making the
laws around gas
around uh you know formula around
contraception like whatever might be
these are the people do you want these
people making the laws that you want to
like in for the country that you live in
if you don't
then you need to do something about you
know coming up this november this
election this new term the midterms so
yeah and i like daryl lee with the five
bucks these stories about boba couldn't
happen to a more vile human being and
i'm all here for she really is a vile
human being i mean you know oh yeah
horror
horror and you know uh
uh
uh three toes yeah yeah uh you know they
are just the two most despicable
dumb
people that we've ever had in congress i
i mean
it's really just i mean
lauren
so i've been taking like two or three
times to pass the ged well
that's that's what it were told and we
don't know if she actually passed the
ged what there is rumor is that someone
else took it for her and then passed it
after two or three times so again who
knows maybe this american muckraker
group will
figure that out right well and again and
again i don't know
we we have not we have not independently
verified this information this is
information that's put out by this group
um they apparently have verified it and
there's going to be more come out from
this group i'm sure um now rather that
damages her politically or
to the point to where she can't win a
primary i don't know i i really i really
don't even put much stock in the ask
watch video of of madison coughlin
trying to [ __ ] his cousin's face i don't
i don't really even know if that was
damaging enough more than just he's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] um and and lauren bobert
the same because they've shown who they
really are to their constituents now
rather they vote them in or not that's
up to those constituents it really is
but here's what i'll tell you about the
ged thing it's the same thing that goes
with the sex work and everything else i
would never discourage anyone from
getting their [ __ ] ged really
honestly i think there's a lot of high
school dropouts out there that are
[ __ ] you're gonna get yours
well i mean you know i am i am i've got
my high school i'm a two kind two time
college dropout but what i will
but what i will say what i will say
though is that um
there there are high school dropouts
that are smarter than lauren bobert and
and that is something that people need
to consider when they're when they're
actually voting for this person rather
she is just a social media influencer
or if she is a really a serious person
who is serious about policy and
government um and actually putting some
thought into it because i think that's
what the republican party is lacking
back to the what the midterms are going
to bring i think if enough people
actually get out and engage i think
they're going to lose badly because
they're nothing but a bunch of social
media [ __ ] they are not politicians
they are not there to set policy i mean
john
jim jordan cannot stop texting about gas
price or tweeting about gas prices he
voted against holding corporations
accountable for gas prices
this guy this guy voted against our
government who who he is saying he's
saying joe biden and the government
needs to do something now they need to
do something they're not doing anything
and he voted against the government
doing something yeah well that's true i
mean that's true of any of the most
recent things that they've you know been
so outraged about is they complain they
complain they complain the democrats say
okay hey we we're coming forward at the
table with the suggestion here as a
resolution you guys want to come in on
this and they go
what do you what are you going to do
actually
you bring up a good point about you know
you know whether the social media
influence or not and ben mentioned it
too is like these people really what
they are you know they're not the best
candidates they're bottom of the barrel
they are scraping the bottom of the
barrel to find people just to fill butts
in the seats that's all they're doing
because when you look at it these people
aren't qualified has lauren barbara
answered to these no i don't know
allegations
he hasn't that we know of yet
and i doubt i doubt i doubt she probably
will until this afternoon this evening
well you know and and getting back to
the canceled culture tony i don't know
about
gabe i don't know if you've heard this
but i just got my second gig cancelled
because my trolls
decided to call the club
and threaten that if they have me
they're gonna give them a one star uh
yelp review and the club was inundated
with calls and they canceled the gig
even though i have a signed contract now
i just hired a lawyer because now i got
to sue them yeah but i mean
well i'm you get it you got to stop you
got it i'm sorry to hear that
i'm still in the club yeah because i
mean you know i have a signed contract
with the club
that if if they cancel i get half the
money but
someone asked me before tony and i'd
love to get your thoughts on this
do i hold kevin
from why do i podcast
do i hold him accountable in some way
and and the answer is yeah because he
started this whole
hate on me you know and and he kept that
going and kept that narrative going
to where he has his fans and i know this
just from all the texts i get in the
instagram
all with his dumb show
title and they and they come after me
so do i hold him accountable i do
what do you think tony well i mean i'm
no lawyer but i mean um if you're if
you're if it's one thing to troll you on
on twitter you know and like tag you
like i don't care about that right but
but when you but when you're actually
taking someone money out of someone's
pocket uh there might be some questions
that have to be answered there um now i
do know based on people tagging me in in
post and stuff um because they always do
this they tag me and they they they
bring up like old content and tick tocks
and
you know they trying to do the same [ __ ]
because ever since ever since we started
coming on the show and i started goofing
on on kevin on why do i podcast they
really they really try to get in our
grill
um which you know i i'll goof on him i
don't give a [ __ ] like he that's that's
his main goal but when he's turning when
he's turning the internet um not just to
goof on you or to troll you or to say
[ __ ] um but but when it comes to like
death threats uh family members and then
taking money into someone's pockets
there's probably gonna i mean there
could possibly it sounds like some legal
stuff there i i you know i'm not a
lawyer i don't know oh
oh oh just so you know tonight i didn't
tell you this i just got
uh a couple of death threats um
somebody texts me
i i didn't want my mom to hear this but
yeah you know like you know telling me
that he's
you know that he's a mobster and that
you know
you know and and again that and again
that goes that goes beyond the scope of
goofy right yeah because we come on here
and we goof you and and and and kevin
kevin does content and he gives you and
but i think i think uh you know he has
to question himself and i actually think
he is here's why because i've seen some
of these posts where they're starting to
say oh i actually like john i like
john's content i just like to goof on
him and and tony and gabe are douche
bags and they don't understand what's
going on i'm like we're the one who's on
jon's show we're the ones who are on
john joe we're the ones who are invited
here to talk to john and we we we gladly
accept those those invitations and we
come on jon's show that's what we do so
so this idea that somehow they love you
and they hate us now i'm like give me a
[ __ ] break because i think they are
now that they see that there's some
ramifications where there's death
threats they're talking about your
family and then they're actually digging
into your pocket with actual money um
when they're doing that when they're
doing that i i think there's i mean
there may be some
i don't know i i don't know i i'm not a
lawyer so i don't know i
i'm going to talk to my lawyer today but
i already hired him and because it's not
because the problem is this is the
second club gabe
uh the first one was corpus christi
because these trolls were calling
that club
saying that they were going to cause
violence towards
women at the club
yes if i
if i appeared there they would hurt
women
that's what they were telling the club
owner so the club owner got scared and
canceled on me
now
this time
we had my agent who's a damn good agent
call them
and
you know warn them that they're gonna
get inundated by some trolls blake greg
thanks for two bucks no i no i i banned
heineken i i don't i won't drink iron
again but anyway
they
so we warned the club
yet the club
gets
five to ten of these losers to call up
and
threaten them
with giving them a one-star yelp review
so then the club gets scared
and they cancel and here's the best part
tony that i i would love to get your
[ __ ] take and gabe
my manager of three years
right
he doesn't call me
you know what he does he sends me an
email dropping me
and i don't even know it yet
so about 21 minutes later
i open my email
and i see
that he's dropping me
because he says that he can't book me
which i understand because these trolls
are doing this but
could you imagine how angry i was
that he didn't even pick up the [ __ ]
phone to call me right yeah and then he
goes well that's you know that's legal i
had to do that because legal i go okay
dante why not call me after you send the
email well i had an important call to
make really you keep saying i'm i'm your
most famous client
you can't [ __ ] pick up the phone and
say john i'm sorry i have to drop you
i'll call you back after i make this
call but no i'll let gabe i like gabe
yeah so he's probably had more
experience yeah uh okay first off this
whole situation is incredibly [ __ ] up
okay the fact that people are you know
it's one thing to goof it's one thing to
joke online you know
roast people whatever
but again once you go into that world of
personal
life
you go into the financial life
that is that is that that begins to go
into the [ __ ] around and find out
situation
that is where
you begin to do stuff you begin to say
stuff you begin to take attacks on
against someone like yourself or or
anyone else
those things become
uh actual
personal
wounds that can be then traced back to
to financial incentives now whether you
know
kevin made the phone call or not like
you can argue that all day and i saw
someone in the comments be like well you
have to prove that kevin made a call
sure that's one thing however
if you're someone who has a show that is
primarily dedicated and if he wants to
argue we only do some content about uh
jon
right regardless
if you have a show where your content is
solely dedicated to attacking or
roasting as he said whatever
and you think it's a joke
but your followers are unable to
decipher the jokes that's right from
animosity
that's where a problem begins to happen
and i think that is where the real case
is led because because kevin
is going to have to answer some
questions about
when you knew these things were
happening and john brought it up about a
previous show or other gigs that he had
that were canceled because of these
trolls
and you did nothing to either say
something you did nothing to either
close down the community
maybe suppress the amount of content
you're doing that is actually
criticizing john or goofing on john or
whatever
then then there is a bit of a
responsibility there
you're allowing people to attack and
you're not saying anything even if you
went on a show and and somebody brought
it up and you say or the end
and kevin said like oh well it's all a
big joke we're just roasting each other
that's you okay that's you but what
about the thousands of other people who
follow you who take what you say
literally who can't understand the
nuance of a joke
regardless of how shitty you are as a
comedian
kevin no offense but offense here yeah
and you look at this right now and you
say
these trolls they take it too far well
the trolls the trolls calling your
comedy clubs and getting your gigs
canceled is only proof that what they're
saying is not funny it's not funny
they're taking it these people are
taking it literally and they're calling
these clubs now i will say that i
haven't watched the um what's the
[ __ ] lady that did an interview with
you it's radio gun what's her name i
don't want this radio gunk
yeah yeah yeah
yeah so so so she did an interview with
with kevin too yeah on her show and she
was my friend well
why i don't know where he [ __ ] stabs
me in the back why i don't i don't know
any of that what i do know is this is
that she even of course they talked
about me on there which is fine i don't
give a [ __ ] if you talk about me i care
less i've said that over and over and
over again over and over and over again
i've said that
and i don't give a [ __ ] you can keep
goofing on me i don't give a [ __ ]
but when you are actually you you are
what appears to be intentionally driving
driving your audience to go damage
someone financially
you might want to you might want to
rethink how you're joking because
the thing about comedy is it doesn't
have to be funny to everyone right it
doesn't have to be funny to everyone you
ha you're making your audience laugh
kevin and and shulie you're making your
audience laugh right who is in front of
you now if you're not making them laugh
you might not be doing that great of a
job
but it but if they're not getting the
joke and they're they're maliciously
getting in people's comments and sending
death threats which they haven't sent me
any death threats i want to be no i got
death threats right well i know but i'm
saying i'm saying them and they they tag
me and [ __ ] and they think they're
[ __ ] funny and they think they're
cool and and all that [ __ ] and there's
like five of them literally there's five
of them and i'm sure it's like
a comedy club that's who just canceled
me right alan comedy
the other thing too is like you know
i i don't really care uh p you know i
mean that's the world that i live in you
know is you're performing entertainment
people people are gonna like it people
aren't going to like it right right it's
one of those main trolls that tries to
come at tony and i which i could give
two [ __ ] about yeah but they you know
every day is a as a new tag where i'm
like
i don't know
yeah sure that i was like yeah that
performance sucks but here's the problem
i'm sorry
here's the problem and getting back to
shulie tony
shirley said that he's gonna be
aft after we talked about his fake uh
twitter followers
he said on one of his shows that he's
going to be relentless towards me
so a friend of mine is speculating that
truly had a lot to do with this
i don't know who does you know i'm not
saying that he did
yeah i have no idea wait wait wait isn't
julia stan doesn't he do stand up or
some [ __ ] yeah which is really
i mean that would be the dumbest thing
because
then people could do the same thing to
him well i mean i mean not only that not
only that but but why if if if he if he
i'm saying he did but if if he if he was
an instigator in it why why would he
think that if people found out about
that would anyone hire him to be a
stand-up in their club no i know
he's willing to torch because the the
comedy clubs regardless if you like the
comedy or not they rely on the people
that come there to perform that's why
they pay the people to perform it's
because they got to get the axe there to
get the [ __ ] i mean everyone knows
the [ __ ] business model it's
capitalism right it's it's capitalism to
get the [ __ ] asses in the seats and
and so if
if if you're
if you're mad that john is getting gigs
because you don't think he's funny you
don't have to go to the [ __ ] you
don't have to buy the ticket i i'm sure
john could give a [ __ ] less
if five trolls from whatever it is over
there why do i podcast buy his [ __ ]
tickets or not i i could i could imagine
that john could care less
but what i'm sure he does care about is
when you actually when you're forcibly
using your accountant to take money out
of his pocket right that that's probably
going to be that's that's i mean again
that's the biggest thing is right like
whether kevin carl whatever is is making
a show that is based on your content
and makes jokes about it
right whether they're like he's like i'm
a comedian
and i'm making jokes and it's it's that
subtle nuance of telling how i can roast
someone or not or whatever he might say
right he's like it's all a joke right it
was just a joke calm down yeah but not
advising
his followers
to stop
or to
kind of understand what's going on right
it becomes malicious it is intentional
it is it is uh it is uh a very it is a
traceable thing that comes back and says
you know did you try to do anything to
stop it
well i i told people it was a joke but
once it was brought up publicly and you
acknowledged that john brought it up
publicly did you say anything
no well
there might be something there that's
connected
look at that comment look at that
comment below though guys it says i saw
a car on i saw that
that carl dude said he doesn't want
anyone to mess with his band's gig yet
he encourages trolls to bother john see
here is here is where he can be held
accountable
he has
a discord on reddit
off of his
you know uh why do i podcast site
that is dedicated to trashing me and
trolling me
so there is where he could be
accountable because he's now
has a whole site
dedicated for all these haters to gather
and that and they tell
because i i know this from a friend told
me they say on there we're gonna go do
this to john today
we're gonna go and troll john's show
today we're gonna cancel john's guests
well it's one thing to be in the chat
because you can block them right it's
not going to be in the gym but it but
when you're when you're actually showing
up
and you're and you're doing and you're
and you're taking money out of someone's
pocket and and you're not just it seems
like you're encouraging it that could be
a problem but here's the thing is if
carl
if carl or kevin whatever you want to
call him is actually saying in his
content which i don't watch his content
no i don't even i seen it i seen someone
post something about the the interview
that he had with um
the radio thing um and and they they i
don't know if they lied about it but
whatever they call be fat or you know
which i am i don't give a [ __ ] um and
and um
uh i'm obviously fat um and and they
said something about um um
i know that carl likes you or some [ __ ]
yeah and but if but if the case is carl
that that cause here's what i'll tell
jon's fans do not
do not
do not try to cancel anyone's gigs
that's not what you should do what you
should do
is to go laugh at their content because
the isotope stuff is [ __ ] totally
laughable it's hilarious it's hilarious
well i want to have you here you know
you know
i was going to have you guys on to goof
on it but at this point it's just like
you know
it's like
i'm damned if i do i'm damned if i don't
because this guy loves the attention you
know what i mean well i i mean here's
the here's the here's the thing too
about um
about kevin's trolls and his troll army
the you know all the tens of them the
tens of people that he has in his troll
army or the tens of accounts that he has
in his troll army um there is a venn
diagram
of of racist misogynist trump humping
dudes and kevin's fans and it's almost a
[ __ ] circle because i've seen them
coming on our youtube channel and say
something about drive-through videos and
then they'll say something about like
really [ __ ] racist or really [ __ ]
misogynistic or something
and
i don't know if i don't know if they
know who their audience is i would guess
they actually do know who their audience
is and they know they're stoking these
these trumped-up [ __ ] to do
this stuff and to cancel john's thing
but that's the other thing that goes i i
would imagine a judge or a jury or
someone would want to see intent is if
they know that's who their audience is i
don't know i just well the other thing
too is one of one of the one of the
trolls tagged me in a video and
sometimes i'll like scroll through and i
saw it and i was like oh what is this
about and in the video they were like oh
well we have great fans and they love us
and all this stuff and i'm like if you
had great fans they wouldn't what who
said this this is carl
yeah well and that's the thing is that's
the thing is uh is that he knows that
that reddit he knows oh yeah
and it because he talks about it he
talks about it he knows what they say he
knows what they post
and because he knows it and he's held
accountable i'm sure
um he knows that if you you're taking
money out of someone's pocket it's a
possibility because i've never seen john
and i don't watch every single minute of
your content john like like kevin does i
know he watches every [ __ ] second of
it because he has to that's the only way
he can make content yes is if he watches
every single second of years even the
gated stuff he has to even pay to watch
your content to make his content which
is kind of pathetic but i've never seen
you once or you've never told me
personally once that you would love to
turn your fan base on him i've never
ever i've never i've never seen that no
no and that's what these people uh
it's like i'm getting accused of like
you know
in the beginning he's like you know when
he first you know i saw the trash me i
used to get mad and you know and i'm
like you know and you know like
you know because i because because i
don't i didn't understand like where the
hell all this anger came from now i
don't even mention the guy the only time
is like when you he's like when you guys
are on it and we try and call him by a
different name kevin
because we're scooping on him right
right we're goofing
i mean we're not telling anyone to go
attack we're not telling anyone to
cancel their live shows
i i actually actually if you want to see
if you want to see john's content a
second time for in the week you could go
watch kevin because he plays john's
content like that's all he does i mean
that's what he does but
the thing is the thing is is that
and they know this they got to know this
that that these that these people are
trying to be malicious it's not about
goofing this isn't about going this
isn't about making fun of john that's
not because it's easy to make fun of
john john admits it we do it on this
show when we come on here yeah it's also
easy to make fun of us right we do that
all the time my tick tocks and my videos
that i have and some of the rants that i
do you are totally welcome to come make
fun of me you know everyone makes money
from my backwards hat and looking like a
limp biscuit and i'm fine with that i'm
cool with that i think that's actually a
funny goof i think that's a funny
[ __ ] goof it's hilarious
but the thing is is when you're
malicious about it when you're going
after someone's when there's death
threats when there's family members
involved that aren't involved in the
content these family members are not
involved in the content right or my
mother at three o'clock that's what i'm
saying right
those are those are very [ __ ] up
things to do and if you're taking
someone money out of someone's pocket
that's that's when the [ __ ] gets real so
that's all i'm saying and then i'm sure
later this week carl will do an episode
covering this thing and saying i never
did that i never told anyone or he'll be
like these guys are so sensitive and
it's like no we don't care if you goof
on us right but if you're taking it
further and you're coming against
someone's income their family
you know you're doxxing them like this
and then you're saying don't come after
my income you're a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
come on man like it's called
i'll just tell you this
i own the copyright on my book
right kevin
puts my audiobook
the mp3 of my complete audio book
on his patreon for free
right
talk about taking money out of my pocket
yeah so he he gets his five ten dollars
for
you know from his patron
and then they get my audio book for free
well and i think i've seen a a clip of
him then this was months ago when we
first started coming on the show he was
talking about something like uh you had
to sue him or something and he's talking
about patreon and he's he's totally
forgetting the terms of service like
patreon gets to decide what [ __ ]
content that guy puts up
patreon does not have to allow him to
put up anything that they don't want him
to have up and if he's stealing patreon
content behind one gate and putting it
behind his gate i'm sure that breaks
terms of service you probably should
learn that [ __ ] word terms of service
no it wasn't just clips he had the whole
mp3 of the book yes
and
mp3 don't [ __ ] tell me adam i know i
went on there and i and i saw it yes he
does the clips of the book too five
shows on my book but he also takes the
mp3 download john's book here right
but the thing is the thing is is that
patreon has the right patreon as a
company because that's the other thing
that they were posting the other day
something about our patreon accounts
i've never [ __ ] pinned my patreon
once and i got one person that pays me
on patreon and by the way if you want to
pay me on patreon just go to
thetonymichaels.com and you'll find it
at the very very bottom my patreon
that's the only time i've ever pent it
so go find it there and i don't know
what you do on patreon but anyways the
point is is that patreon has the right
for you to be a user
and him to be a user and to tell you
what you can or cannot post there it is
their [ __ ] platform and if they do
not want him taking your patreon content
and making content out of it they can do
that if they want especially if it
breaks their terms of service which i've
never looked at their terms of service
and i actually i should i did because i
hit agree
but you know i just i was like agree
yeah sure
sure
so and but anyways yeah if you want to
be a patron of mine absolutely and
they're going to be like oh see he's a
grifter he's a grifter look burnout uh
thanks for the five bucks dr steve
offered to pay you for an appearance
john you said no why if you want to
profit off them like usa
first of all i think he's referring to i
guess this guy was gonna offer me like a
thousand dollars to go on kevin's
podcast i ain't doing that for a
thousand dollars three thousand maybe
but not a thousand i mean i'm not that
big of a sellout weren't they weren't
they trying to take a poll rather than
have me on their show or not or some
[ __ ] i don't know do they end up doing
that i don't i don't know i don't know
well listen guys i you know i hate to
say but i do gotta go because i gotta
pick what i don't hate to say i i enjoy
saying that i have to go drive my son to
uh the two and see you hate not seeing
us just yeah yeah yeah
but listen tony gabe plug whatever you
want i love having you guys on and it
was great to have the midas touch guys
on and then you guys
uh so please you know uh plug anything
you want yeah we'll watch our show every
single weekday on youtube go follow our
our youtube channel the tony michaels
podcast and go over to midas touch and
watch us on all the hearings i know
tomorrow's got postponed but it looks
like thursday is is going to be uh in a
morning uh uh hearing so go watch that
on minus touch we'll have coverage front
to back we'll do an hour before so it'll
start at 9 00 a.m eastern now for that
airing coverage gabe i don't know if you
got the text or not but it looks like
they're going to do two hearings next
week right so
i don't know i don't know what the first
one is but the second one is obviously
happening on thursday which yeah yeah
and then
so however many hearings come join us on
the minus touch podcast channel on
youtube but also follow us the tony
michaels podcast on youtube and catch us
every single weekday monday through
friday all right thanks guys i love
having you on yep see ya
all right the great tony michaels and uh
gabe sanchez i want to thank them for
coming on i also want to thank ben
myself and jordy myself from the minus
touch brothers for coming on i also want
to thank all you generous people for the
super chats i really do appreciate it i
also want to thank um my moderator today
uh andrea brauer
who did a wonderful job all by her
lonesome i appreciate it i also want to
thank my sponsor bet online.ag
um and i always thank my other moderator
uh nikki b
who i guess couldn't be here today
um
uh
hi to my grandson i think my mother just
said to say that
um
[Music]
wait say hello to grahams i don't i
don't know anyway um
i
will have a new show on thursday at noon
pst and
seriously thoughts and prayers to the
cast and family i am so
so sorry about your loss
you know it puts everything into
perspective
you know i mean oh you know you know who
cares about a gig when you
have just lost a child i mean god i
don't know how you could handle that and
i felt so bad
sean and i give my i you know i give my
thoughts and praise to your family
and um
uh it's so sad
so uh
that's it i i do gotta go thank you
blake craig for the two bucks beth is a
great person she's a lovely person
uh all right i'll see you guys on
thursday stuttering john saying geeky